today's video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building your brand and growing your
business online more about them in a bit
according to 4G magazine or when
personal wealth is measured as a
percentage of the contemporaneous gross
domestic product or GDP Steven Gerard is
ranked fourth on the list of wealthiest
Americans in history he was also the
first multi-millionaire in the United
States decades before the writer Horatio
Alger popularized the rags to richest
Tale in America Stephen Gerard lived one
yet outside of his adopted hometown of
Philadelphia he's virtually unknown his
vast Fortune most of which he bequeathed
charity continues to support
philanthropic projects as they have
since his death on December 26 1831
ironically the Feast of Stephen he
wasn't given that name at Birth but
rather the French version of the name
Ator when he was christened in Bordeaux
France in 1750. his father Rose from
common sailor to Port Captain a position
of considerable Authority among Merchant
Seaman sources regarding attila's early
life are scant although it is known that
he had no vision in his right eye
probably from from birth since in
letters he wrote years later he noted no
recollection of ever having been cited
in that eye he had little in the way of
Education in his youth beginning his
career by going to see as a cabin boy at
the age of 14 two years after the death
of his mother by the time that career
ended with his own death in 1831 he had
a master Fortune of 7.5 million pounds a
1 1 50th of the United States GDP at the
time only John D Rockefeller John Jacob
Aster and Cornelius Vanderbilt built
fortunes that reflected his larger
portion of the national economy he had
also financed the American war effort
during the War of 1812 largely from his
own Pockets created charitable and
educational institutions that still
exist and built the first Private Bank
in America nearly all his life had been
conducted away from the public stage
avoiding the spotlight it All Began in
the Humble Home of a sailor on the Rue
Ramone
then just a small village outside
Bordeaux on the river in France
foreign
of the war of the Austrian succession
during a British Fleet attack on the
French Anchorage breast Philippe served
aboard a vessel damaged by an English
far ship Gerard's heroism during the
action in which he was credited with
extinguishing the fire and saving his
ship LED King Louis XV to Grant him a
ward that included the Royal military
order of San Luis following the war his
Fame led him to a position as a minor
Authority in Bordeaux with considerable
influence over the port's shipping and
Mercantile trade he issued the licensers
allowing ships to enter or exit the port
he married a dead LaFarge in 1748 and
from this Union eventually 10 children
emerged the second of which and their
first son they named details of patience
early life are scarce other than the
surviving records of the births of his
siblings and those of the death of his
mother his known Story begins in 1764
when he shipped as a cabin boy aboard
one of his father's ships Philip has a
merchant in Seaman and maintained a
Brisk trade with the French colonies in
the West Indies including Porter Prince
on the island of San Domingo where etiar
journeyed on his first voyage he learned
the sea going trade quick Theme by 1773
he was designated as an officer
equivalent to a lieutenant in the French
Navy in terms of knowledge and
responsibility within another year he
was the equivalent of a captain holding
the license necessary for him to assume
command of a ship under French law atar
received his license without having to
fulfill the then prevalent requirement
of serving two years as an officer in
the naval vessel before rising to
command status in the merchant Fleet but
he was able to circumvent the law is an
indication of the influence will Dubai's
father in 1774 etiar sailed for San
Domingo in command of the ship La Julie
on a voyage in which he owned a share of
the cargo being delivered as Captain he
had the right to purchase deliverables
on credit sell them to Planters and
Merchants at his destination and pay as
creditors upon his return to Bordeaux
when it here sailed from Bordeaux on
their Voyage it was the last time he
laid eyes on the city of his birth his
portion of the cargo sold for far less
than what he had paid for it on credit
in addition he was responsible as
Captain for collecting the payments for
the rest of the cargo to be dispersed to
the creditors back in France upon his
ship's return they too fell short unable
to pay his debts upon return and fearful
of debt as prison at your petitioned for
discharge which was granted in June
1774. he then cast about for another
cargo to be purchased with what
literally had collected on the goods he
had brought across the Atlantic he found
one in coffee and sugar and after
procuring a small coasting vessel he
carried that cargo to New York his
father wrote him of his despair to son's
failure to honor his debts at all
replied that he planned to return after
he raised enough money in the colonies
to clear his debts he never did that
though so are you looking to build a
website that truly represents your brand
well look no further than today's
sponsor Squarespace Squarespace is the
perfect all-in-one platform for building
your brand and growing your business
online stand out with a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
you can even sell anything your products
your content even a year time so now
let's talk about some of the amazing
features that Squarespace offers first
up member areas like if you're an
educator or a Creator you can easily
monetize your content by selling access
to gated content like online courses and
newsletters and if you're looking to
expand your email marketing strategy
Squarespace email campaigns is the way
to go you can collect subscribes and
turn them into loyal customers with
customizable email templates that match
your Brand Plus analytics tools will
help you gain insight into your site's
visitors and their interactions with
your content and for all of you bloggers
out there Squarespace has got you
covered with powerful tools to share
your stories photos videos and updates
finally Squarespace lets you connect
your social media accounts to your
website so you can automatically push
website content to your favorite social
media channels making it easier for your
followers to share your content so what
are you waiting for go to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase or a website or a
domain don't forget to use the code
biographics at checkout thanks to
Squarespace for sponsoring and now back
to today's video
in New York eteon took employment as a
mate for the shipping concern owned by
Thomas Randall he made several voyages
along the American Coast from New York
including to New Orleans with each
generating modest profits both for
Randall and son and his own private
interests such was his situation when
war broke out between the British North
American colonies and Great Britain in
April 1775. War increased the dangers of
the sea yet it also created additional
opportunities for experienced and
skilled semen by then etion was
knowledgeable about the West Indies the
Caribbean and most of the American
Coastline he was ready to capitalize on
those opportunities Gerard took Refuge
from a severe storm sea in Philadelphia
and remained there when the British
captured New York in 1776. his employer
Thomas Randall likewise fled from New
York to elude the British together the
men started a new trading firm in
Philadelphia it was around that time a
tiagara began referring to himself as
Stephen under that name he purchased a
home in Mount Holly New Jersey a
Counting house and warehouse for his
trade goods in Philadelphia Alpha and
over the ensuing years several ships
including privateers Randall established
himself in San Domingo brokering goods
from France and Spain arriving in the
regions via Saint eustaceus from there
trade between the islands and gerrar in
Philadelphia was forced to run the
gauntlet of British Men of War this was
a dangerous business and Gerard's
captains adopted several rouges of War
acceptable during that era including
flying the flags of different nations
and carrying false cargo manifests and
bills of lading during the Revolutionary
War Girard established roots in
Philadelphia both professionally and
personally in 1777 he married Mary Lunn
the daughter of a Philadelphia
shipbuilder the following year after the
British occupation of the city ended
Gerard was confronted with the decision
the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania having
adopted a Constitution which offered
freedom for all demanded an oath of
loyalty to the Revolutionary cause as a
condition of that freedom refusal to
take the oath rendered a person
ineligible to conduct business in the
former Colony refusal also made a
person's property subject to seizure by
the state at the time Girard remained a
subject of the king of France though he
opted to swear allegiance to
Pennsylvania the governor and
legislature and the Revolutionary cause
he was granted status as a citizen of
Pennsylvania and resident of
Philadelphia with all the rights and
privileges of such including the rights
to pay taxes and vote Mary and Stephen
who until then had resided at his Mount
Holly home moved to Philadelphia and
purchased another home there Stephen
worked to expand not only his shipping
interests but also his rapidly growing
Mercantile business in the city by the
end of the Revolutionary War he held a
fortune in ships local real estate and
the rarest of all Commodities in the
fledgling United States hard currency
yeah
International Trade significantly
strangled during the Revolutionary War a
returned with gusto after the fighting
ended it was not without risks for one
ships flying the new stars and stripes
did not enjoy the protection of the
British Navy as had ships from American
ports before the war piracy in the
Caribbean although no longer in his
Heyday still menaced the British also
imposed regulations on what could and
could not be traded with their former
colonies as well as which British ports
could accept which cargos the Atlantic
slave trade grisly and profitable
occupied the attention and efforts of
Traders in Europe and North America as
well as those of Smugglers and Pirates
there was effectively no national
government in the United States Seabourn
trade was regulated by each of the
former colonies through local Customs
officials Pennsylvania could and often
did Issue restrictions against cargos
arriving from South Carolina for example
when similar Goods could be acquired
more cheaply elsewhere tariffs were
imposed by the state's legislatures as
well as import fees shipping rates taxes
licenses certificates of rank for
Mariners limitations on cargos and so
forth Baltimore for example charged
different rates for goods from
Pennsylvania than for the same good ship
from say Boston or from French ports
each of the 13 States considered others
to be foreign Nations to circumvent the
Maze of shipping regulations merchants
and ship captains adopted methods
similar to those used during the war
Girard and other Traders used false
documents disguised cargos and
counterfeit ships Registries to move
their goods between the states despite
the risks involved which included the
seizure of vessels and cargos the
potential for profits remained enormous
Girard as well as other Traders ran the
risk of circumventing the regulations
attracted by the Seas enormous potential
for profits for them the end Justified
the means Gerard expanded both his
Mercantile business and his shipping
Fleet in the years of the Articles of
Confederation failed harvests in France
increased the demand for wheat and flour
there and Gerard responded by shipping
large cargo's french ports trading with
a firm operated by his brother Jean
Girard he also speculated in wheat
prices gambling on further crop failures
in France his risk proved well placed
additional crop failures led to further
shortages of bread in France higher
prices for exported wheat and eventually
the bread rods of 1787 a precursor to
the French Revolution before the
American Revolution most Merchant ships
cleared their ports with their captains
owning a percentage of the cargo with
which they were Laden this often led to
captains waiting to sail or enter a
foreign Port until optimal conditions
for the sale of the cargo were present
Gerard had made considerable profits as
a sea-going master at this practice he
decided though it was not optimal for
his ships or his business Girard
established the practice of hiring his
captains at an established wage and
offered bonuses of projected delivery
schedules were made on time ownership of
the vessels remained his alone and the
cargos belonged to shippers and
investors often including himself
foreign
by 1785 Stephen and Mary's marriage was
although an otherwise a happy Union
troubled by Mary's steadily increasing
fits and emotional outbursts they began
to withdraw from Philadelphia's Social
Scene which was an active one
particularly when the Congress of the
Confederation was in session Mary was
diagnosed with an incurable mental
instability leading to Girard hiring a
full-time nurse to care for his wife
mental health care in the late 18th
century was virtually non-existent all
that could be done was ensure the
patient did no harm to herself or to
others and see to her personal and
physical needs as Mary's condition
worsened the constitutional convention
was held in Philadelphia France
descended into its own Madness and
girard's wealth continued to grow so did
his influence with the emerging
politicians and their views Philadelphia
was then the nation's largest city as
well as its larger shipping Port Gerard
was the city's wealthiest Merchant and
shipper his views on the nation's
ability to impose tariffs and irregulate
trade were no doubt expressed both
during the convention and in the early
years of the new government yet he kept
his views private expressing the money
and confidence Mary's condition
continued to deteriorate and Gerard soon
began an affair with one of his wife's
many nurses by 1790 air condition was so
alarming that she could no longer be
cared for in their home Stephen had his
wife committed to the Pennsylvania
Hospital in the late summer of that year
his wealth ensuring that she had all she
required she arrived pregnant giving
birth to a daughter whom she named Mary
a few months later the infant died
shortly after birth her father's
identity unknown to posterity Mary
remained at the Pennsylvania hospital
until her death there in 1815. while
Gerard paid for her care and ensured
that she was provided as luxurious
accommodations as were possible he did
not visit her other than when Consulting
with her doctors over potential
treatments they remained married for the
rest of her life and on her death
Stephen had her buried in the hospital
Cemetery in an unmarked grave for the
rest of his life he consoled himself
with a series of Mistresses having no
known children to inherit his vast
wealth he never remarried
coastal cities in early America are
subject to epidemics during the warmer
months of the year in particular those
borne by mosquitoes including bouts of
yellow fever and malaria are among
others in 1783 and again in 1787 yellow
fever struck the capital at Philadelphia
the government fled the city as did the
wealthier citizens relocating to what
they believed to be the healthier air if
the hills away from the putrid Waters
and the rivers and streams which fed the
Estuary upon which Philadelphia have
been built in 1793 alone over 5000
philadelphians succumbed to Yellow Fever
at disease little understood by the
medical professionals of the time Girard
perhaps because of the medical
profession's helplessness in the face of
his wife's illness had a low opinion of
medicine in general a malignant fever
which has prevailed here for the last
month added to the ignorance of our
doctors has carried off more than four
thousand of our friends he wrote this to
a business associate in 1793 at the
height of that Year's epidemic led by
Girard the hospital for the care and
treatment of The Afflicted during the
yellow fever epidemic was established
Gerard purchased and donated the
building served as its director and
worked tirelessly to obtain food bedding
furnishings and nursing care for the
stricken his efforts extended to him
actively nursing veal himself in his
correspondence to business associates
both in Europe and the other states he
expressed his contempt for the medical
profession's helplessness in the face of
superstition and illness on suggested
treatment was the burning of nightly
bonfires and he announced his business
Affairs would be secondary until the
epidemic had run its course the 1793
yellow fever epidemic followed by
additional attacks in 1797 1802 and 1820
marked at the beginning of Gerard's
charitable activities all of which were
to focus on education adequate housing
and Healthcare in addition to his
donations to the Pennsylvania hospital
today part of the University of
Pennsylvania Gerard supported the public
school fund of Philadelphia the society
for the relief of distressed masters of
ships and their widows the Pennsylvania
Institution for the deaf and dumb
today's Pennsylvania School for the Deaf
and the Philadelphia orphan Society
foreign
in February 1791 the First Bank of the
United States was chartered as a
National Bank it was allowed to
establish branches in all states all of
the banks in the U.S were chartered by
the states and allowed to establish
branches only in their home state
Alexander Hamilton then Secretary of the
Treasury was an early and hard and
supporter of establishing a National
Bank some political leaders among the
Madison Jefferson and Washington opposed
the idea Washington even considered
vetoing the legislation which created
the bank though his hereticence was
based on constitutional rather than
financial concerns the bank's Charter
ran for 20 years and it remained
controversial throughout those two
decades in 1811 the charter expired and
Congress refused to renew it leading
Gerard to purchase most of the remaining
shares its building on Philadelphia's
South 3rd Street and its equipment and
Furnishings although he gave his bank no
name it quickly became known in
Philadelphia as girard's Bank he
operated it as a sole proprietorship of
aiding what would have otherwise
violated state law requiring a charter
from the Statewide operate he get much
of the bank's activities hidden which as
a private Enterprise he was entitled to
do Shiraz Bank privately held and
operated financed shipping Ventures and
other Investments and added
substantially to his continually growing
wealth then the United States after
Decades of enduring British and French
interference with its international
trade and shipping rights declared war
on the former in 1812. Gerard supported
the government's actions to defend
American free trade rights at a time
when most wealthy merchants concerned
over the loss of business war with
Britain would lead to opposed the effort
by 1813 the US government was bankrupt
without money and without viable credit
it appeared the Americans would lose
their first declared war Gerard used his
personal Fortune through his bank to
shore up the faltering American economy
and continue the war by 1813 girard's
loans the federal government through the
purchase of government bonds contributed
up to 95 of the federal budget in effect
funding the American war effort through
his own pocket eventually the Americans
and British arrived at a peace agreement
without loss of property by either died
though the post-treaty American victory
at the Battle of New Orleans left a many
with the impression that the Young
Nation had won the war Gerard's timely
Financial intercession saved the
American war effort in the post-wear of
good feelings as the administration of
James Monroe became known the American
economy flourished Gerard's war bonds
purchased at considerable risk matured
and made him yet more Millions
foreign
years Steven Gerard continued a
lucrative trade with China begun before
the war including participation in the
opium trade in 1824 an altercation
involving all of his ships and Chinese
authorities ended that branch of his
business he continued to operate his
bank and his trading Enterprise as well
as his many charitable activities
becoming well known for his penchant for
walking from his businesses to his home
in what is today South Philadelphia it
was during one such walk that he was
struck by a carriage on Market Street in
December 1830. he never fully recovered
from the injury sustained in the
accident and he died on December 26
1831. he was 81 years old his last will
and testament was challenged by
relatives in France and in the Caribbean
when its contents became known in early
1832. they were concerned that the vast
bulk of his fortune over 7 million
dollars had been left for the
establishment of a school in his own
words for poor white male orphans Gerard
insisted of the school which he called a
college that no ecclesiastical
missionary or minister of any sect
whatsoever shall ever hold or exercise
any station or Duty or whatever in the
said College his relatives objected to
the will on the grounds it discriminated
against Christian teachings in 1844 the
Supreme Court of the United States
upheld girard's will and in 1848 Gerard
College opened in Philadelphia at the
time it held the largest endowment of
any educational institution in America
all of it from Gerard's personal Fortune
it remains in operation to this day an
independent boarding school offering
classes in grades 1 through 12 for
students from single-parent low-income
families several of its buildings still
in use were designed with personal input
from Gerard during his lifetime and in
the instructions of his will the school
was desegregated in 1968 and the first
female students were admitted in 1984.
over 90 percent of the school's
graduates go on to higher education a
rate which greatly exceeds that of
Philadelphia's Public Schools following
his death several employees and his
private bank purchased the assets and
Furnishings of that business and opened
the Gerard trust company which remained
in business until its merge with melon
Bank in 1983 though Steven Gerard had
nothing to do with the Enterprise other
than the use of his name a biography of
Gerard written by a former employee
Steven Simpson appeared in 1832 titled
biography of Steven Gerard Simpson
pointed out the several times throughout
Gerard's career where he ignored past
debts taking advantage of events such as
the French Revolution the slave revolts
in Haiti and others in Haiti for example
Gerard learned of several Planters who
had already paid him for goods being
imprisoned and simply resold the goods
he owed them profiting twice while
ignoring his customers Misfortune though
most of Simpson's assertations were
discounted by historians many were true
reflecting girard's opportunism as well
as the ruthless nature of his business
transactions Steven Gerard was the
wealthiest man in America at the time of
his death and one whose Fortune
continues to benefit philadelphiaans and
by extension his adopted country much of
his fortune was earned through what a
modern eye may consider less than
scrupulous means including piracy
smuggling insider trading War profit
hearing and speculation he built his
fortune through often surreptitious
means behind the scenes yet he put up
that fortune to good use in the service
of his country and its people in War and
Peace sickness and health boom and bust
like the man who bequeathed it that
fortune remains behind the curtain
steadily at work away from the lighted
stage